la chaîne de solidarité s'est agrandie
pendant la crise sanitaire plusieurs
chefs notamment se sont joints à l'élan
pour cuisiner en faveur des personnels
hospitaliers avec nous jean baptiste
laverny mourad zanni bonsoir bonsoir
bien connu dans les yvelines chef étoilé
de la table du 11 à versailles
propriétaires aussi de la cave est du
bistrot du onze alors vous avez
participé à l'opération un bon repas
pour bien soigner elle a été lancé cette
opération par la fondation hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france pour le lundi
de pâques vous avez cuisine et 50 repas
au centre hospitalier de montreuil mais
les landes va pas s'arrêter puisque vous
allez de nouveau cuisiner ce week-end
c'est ça pour d'autres hôpitaux
ouais tout à fait voilà en fait on
essaie de
de faire un rendez vous hebdomadaire
pour pouvoir cuisiner une on essaye de
passer à deux fois par semaine
donc tu vas l'idée c'est de récupérer
des denrées avec tous les commerçants de
versailles qui font vraiment preuve les
suédois super élan et il ya vraiment un
élan de générosité qui est assez
impressionnant cette ville là on ne
récupère aujourd'hui toute la
marchandise pour dimanche ça sera
peut-être de l'europe à guyancourt et on
va essayer de donner ce rendez vous là
tous les dimanches et c'est ce que je
vous disais juste avant on va essayer de
rentrer un rendez vous de plus dans la
semaine
pourquoi c'est important pour vous
justement de se joindre à l'élan de
solidarité que l'on voit dans toutes les
professions en ce moment pourquoi aussi
apporter votre pierre à l'édifice
cuisiner pour pour ce personnel
hospitalier va pour deux choses d'une
part d'une part je pense que je pense
que nous on a des mains avant on avait
notre potager notre potager qui ne
servait plus à rien tu fais que le
restaurant était fermé et ça a démarré
comme ça à l'envi l'envi de de servir à
quelque chose
il est des gens qui sont dans le besoin
actuel qui seront dans des difficultés
au quotidien que nous on voit de loin
moi je suis très respectueux de tous ces
métiers là je l'étais déjà mais je suis
encore plus aujourd'hui parce que je
pense qu'on sera encore plus compte de
ce que ça représente et je pense que
c'est la moindre des choses leur donne
un coup de main à moindre échelle mais
voilà si ça peut leur donne un peu de
baume au coeur aux joues et surtout pas
qu'on parle de nous c'est vraiment pas
l'idée c'est vraiment l'idée qu'on parle
des soignants et qu'ils soient du mieux
possible au quotidien voilà si on peut
les rassurer en reste un bon repas et
l'opération vous allez me le confirmer
elle a été rendue possible aussi parce
que cette chaîne de générosité se sont
joints les commerçants de versailles
vous n'êtes pas seuls vous êtes
accompagné des commerçants de versailles
l'initiative vient de laurence lorenzo
qui a acquis et président de
l'association la maison de valentin est
celle qui a fait ce lien et cette chaîne
cette chaîne
cette chaîne dans versailles avec tous
les commerçants donc vous avez gaudin
yanni gourde et la boulangerie vous avez
fromagerie le gall et j'en oublie il y
en a plein et qui donnent chacun ce
qu'ils peuvent ensuite on les livre aux
restaurants et et on les cuisine et puis
on les livre les lieux on les livre le
lendemain alors vous allez nous dire
dans un instant qu est ce que vous avez
prévu de puiser ce week end mais là pour
le lundi de pâques
quel était le menu pour le personnel de
l'hôpital de montreuil bas pour le lundi
de pâques du coup on a fait on a fait le
fameux newsletters donc on a fait l
gigot qui était braisé accompagné des
cartes d'un maraîcher avec qui on
travaille
et ensuite on a c'est un petit crème de
bris avec raison corinthe et aider à
noah hosties vente et en dessert un
petit fondant chocolat avec une
confiture de lait fait frétiller nos
papilles il ya peut-être des yvelinois
qui s'apprête à passer à table qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu pour ce week-end le
cuisiner ce week-end on a réussi à avoir
des poulets donc on va faire un poulet
avec un bon gratin de pommes de terre
avec gratinées au fromage à raclette
ensuite on va car un camembert avec avec
paris raison ça on va chercher à faire
quelque chose d'un peu original et on va
faire un petit chèque en terminer de
quoi nous donner
l'appétit vous le disiez ça va se
poursuivre au delà de ce week-end l'idée
c'est de reproposer ce rendez-vous le
plus régulièrement possible
ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est c'est
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ce confinement
est d'aller au bout de
jusque jusque quand les difficultés
seront terminées dans les hôpitaux
donc voilà temps content qu'on peut le
faire on va le faire avec grand plaisir
et et puis j'espère que d'autres chefs
il ya plein d'autres chefs qui le font
parce que ça va continuer et il faut
surtout pas lâcher je pense que l'on
rentre dans le plus difficile commence à
en avoir marre et voilà faut vraiment
renforcer nos envies de et bien merci et
bravo jean baptiste la v12 mourad ainy
bravo aussi aux commerçants de
versailles je rappelle que vous êtes
merci d'avoir été avec toi je rappelle
que vous êtes le chef de la table du 11
à versailles et merci pour cette belle
initiative en faveur du personnel
hospitalier qui mérite bien en ce moment
là compris un bon repas bravo d'ailleurs
à tous les personnels soignants